[Music]
like it just looks like the form of a
woman's body to me I mean it's beautiful
it really is a spectacular cart this
just really turns me the fact that
yourself go across it don't mind us it's
just the camera I'm Oliver Trevino
welcome to car collectors in New York
and we'll check out some bug eyes
[Music]
hi I'm David s'il-vous-plait welcome to
bug eye guide.com
come on in and I'll give you a tour nice
to meet you sir oh you are mister bug hi
mister mister mister frogeye to you frog
eye my guy in America frog eye in
Britain
this car is obviously called a bug I cut
Siddis headlights initially these were
gonna be pop ups so they were gonna go
in the nose and then come out but they
couldn't afford that at the time so they
just plunked the headlights on the front
and hence the bug I was born when they
first came out they were seventeen
hundred and ninety-five dollars
it was really a poor man's sports car
and now a really nice bug I is twenty
five to thirty thousand dollars this
little baby this one is kind of the
ultimate bug eye it looks totally
stocked now remember they made about
50,000 of these cars so how many are
less does anybody's guess I'm I'm gonna
guess somewhere around ten thousand of
them are still out there what's special
about this one is that the original bug
I had 43 horsepower this one probably
has an 85 horsepower so you're looking
at 0 to 60 now in ten seconds nine
seconds
this was the first of a big Healey that
they made this is an austin-healey 104
or 100 minus a 4 this grille nobody
makes a grill like this what we're
disgusting it's hard to find one of
these for less than 40,000 and the
really beautiful restored ones and the
modified ones can be upwards of a
hundred thousand and I'm a British
masterpiece if I do say so myself this
car is a 62 model the mark 2 models so
they didn't make all that many so you
get this little mark 2 badge I think
sometimes people are a little you know
they back away a little because it's
almost too nice or two distinctive she's
unapproachable perhaps she's friendly
she's very friendly thanks for showing
us around these amazing vehicles car
envy I'm gonna be bug eyed for the
receipt yeah you will be you could go on
the website it's bug-eye guide.com and
we always have about 10 bug eyes for
sales so we can make you a pink one if
you want alright let us know what your
favorite car is subscribe to GQ comm
comment below and you can tweet us as
well
[Music]